Commentator: David is a world-renowned journalist
who started his career at the Washington Post,
spending 4 years in Russia.
And since 1998, David has been the editor
of the New Yorker Magazine, and he has led
the New Yorker to receive more than 24 national
or international awards for excellence in
journalism, including Advertising Age's editor
of the year, which has been awarded to him.
He has written a number of books. He is a
Pulitzer Prize winner; Polk award winner for
his book "Lenin's Tomb". He's also written
books known as "The Resurrection", "The Devil's
Problem: And Other True Stories", as well
as reporting, and King Of the World, about
Muhammad Ali. And his latest book is called
"The Bridge: The Life and Rise of Barak Obama".
And David has put together here one of the
most comprehensive biographies and stories
of the rise of how this historic election
happened by really drawing on hundreds of
interviews of people who have been close colleagues
of the President's, who worked to get him
elected, and actually the President himself.
We're going to end the talk a little early
at 1:50. So there will be a little time for
book signings, and you can interact personally
with David afterwards. And for the Q&A, at
the end, we'd like to ask everyone to use
the microphones so the Youtube and VC audiences
can participate. Please, help me welcome David
Remnick.
[Applause]
David Remnick: Good afternoon. You in the
back.
[Laughter]
Don't hit the doors, okay. Here's what I think
we should do. I'll talk about the book for
a while, but I swear to God I'm not going
to go on for half an hour. That seems a fruitless
enterprise, but I'd like to give you a sense
of what this book is because there's a book
that looms next to my book, it is called "Dreams
from My Father". And it's a reasonable question
to ask why somebody would attempt to write
a book about Barak Obama, very briefly into
his presidency, where, after all, we are only
about 15, 16 months into the presidency. What's
this all about? Well, the historical dimension
of Barak Obama's presidency, the most radical
thing about Barak Obama, is very simply something
we don't talk a hell of a lot about much anymore,
is the fact that he is the first African-American
president. And it is a remarkable fact of
history, a remarkable phenomenon in history
that we have a kind of mechanism of forgetting
some of the landmarks that have occurred very
quickly because we're so immersed in the subjects
of the here and the now. The subjects of health
care, the subjects of foreign affairs, the
subjects of financial regulation, and all
the things we're reading about on the front
pages of the newspaper. It's very hard to
live in the now and in history at the same
time and be very conscious of it.
Why is it called "The Bridge"? The Bridge
is the opening scene of the book, and it's
something that introduces the themes of Barak
Obama's career, and the themes of the candidacy
for the presidency. In 1965, very few will
remember necessarily, in 1965 in March there
was an enormously important landmark in the
civil rights movement. People in Selma, Alabama,
marched for voting rights or attempted to,
led by SNCC. John Lewis, who is now a congressman
in Georgia, and other leaders of the Southern
Christian Leadership Conference tried to begin
a march across the state of Alabama from Selma,
which had been a real seat of the Confederacy,
to the state capital, Montgomery, where the
governor sits, and the governor of that time,
if you remember, was George Wallace. And on
the first attempt to make this march, the
demonstrators were met by a battalion of vigilantes
and police. And they were beaten near to death,
some of them. John Lewis' head was bashed
in from the instant they started the march
and many others were beaten and gassed and
hit by dogs, and all the rest of the iconic
and very real incidence of the civil rights
movement and moments of nonviolent resistance
met by violent actions of the police. Several
days later, the attempt to march from Selma
to Montgomery was successful. It was led by
Martin Luther King and other civil rights
leaders, including again John Lewis. And Lyndon
Johnson witnessed these spectacles -- both
of the violent ones and of the march itself
and enacted what we now know as the "Voting
Rights Act". Remember, African-Americans in
the South, in places like Selma, Alabama,
in places in Georgia and Mississippi and all
the rest, effectively de facto did not have
the right to vote. They were thwarted by exams,
all kinds of poll taxes, all of sort of preventative
measures taken by the Southern leadership
in the aftermath of reconstruction that lasted
until the mid-60s. So that moment in our history,
now it seems to have receded in the past and
receded in memory, was enormously and powerfully
received by African-Americans in the mid-60s
and became a vital part of our history. And
every year since 1965, there's been a reenactment
of, a celebration of both the "Bloody Sunday",
the march, voting rights, and every year people
gather led by John Lewis and other members
of the civil rights movement to commemorate
this incident. In March 2007, at yet another
annual convening of this movement, Barak Obama,
a newly minted presidential candidate, having
just announced in Springfield maybe 6 weeks
before came to Selma. In Springfield, he had
spoken to the entire nation, the metaphor
that he used was Abraham Lincoln. When he
came to Selma, the intention was to speak
directly to the African-American community.
He did not have the black vote by any means
wrapped up; in fact he was being outdistanced
by Hillary Clinton of course.
The Clintons have deep relations with the
black vote, with black leaders, with people
like John Lewis, and many, many other black
leaders throughout the country and for good
reason. Do you remember in the New Yorker
magazine, Toni Morrison had written many years
before that the first black president was,
in fact, Bill Clinton. She was kind of joking
around, but she kind of wasn't. She kind of
wasn't. That she thought, here was this guy
who was a white Southerner who, when it concerned
race, he got it.
And so Obama gave this incredibly adroit speech.
He gets up in front of-in Brown Chapel, which
is "the" Church where all the great civil
rights leaders including Malcolm X had spoken
the resonant place and behind him was John
Lewis, C. T. Vivian, Joseph Lowery, and any
number of elders of the civil rights movement.
And he essentially turned to them and said,
"I stand on the shoulders of giants. I am
here because of you. You are the great members
of the Moses generation, and I pay tribute
to you and all of my generation of people
in their 30s and 40s and 50s pay tribute to
you. But you remember from your biblical history
that Moses doesn't get to see the Promised
Land. Moses gets to approach the Promised
Land, look over and see the Promised Land,
but he is prevented from getting there. I,
Barak Obama, and the leader of the Joshua
Generation, and I am here because of you",
and it's an incredibly galling thing to do.
It's an incredibly ballsy thing to do, for
a political candidate to do. And Barak Obama
among his many attributes, positive attributes,
is not lacking for considerable sense of self.
[Laughter]
You don't run for president, and basically
say, I am the ideal person to lead the United
States of America if not the free world and
lack for ego. And anybody who does and tries
to attempt it gets eaten up alive. In fact,
the presidents that we seem to have the most
contempt for sometimes are the ones that do
not have sufficient ego rather than too much
of it. Anyway, so he gives this speech. He
takes some poetic license with his own past.
He suggests that somehow his own father got
to the United States, and received an American
education, thanks to the Kennedys and tries
to draw a line between the Kennedy funding
of an airlift of Kenyan scholars and students.
Not quite true. The Kennedys kicked in money
after Obama had gotten to the United States.
But okay. But he tries to say to the black
community, "It is true that my father is African,
and is not in the normal or normative line
from the slave generations. He is African
and my mother is white and I was raised in
a very particular and peculiar way, but I
am here for the same reason you are here.
I am here and I'm an African American and
I'm here because of what these people sitting
behind me did. What they suffered, what they
went through, and all the rest." And the battle
commenced.
The battle commenced -- the battle for the
black vote, because in this country in order
to get the Democratic nomination for president,
the African-American vote is crucial. So on
the one hand, this book, "The Bridge", is
about Obama's thrust towards the presidency.
On the other hand, it's about the social forces,
the historical forces that allowed him to
get there that made it possible. Things like
the history of Chicago politics. The history
of African American politics in this country.
Things like Jesse Jackson's campaign in 1984
and 1988. There is no Barak Obama without
Jesse Jackson no matter what you may think
of Jesse Jackson, and some of you may have
clear memories of those campaigns and some
foggier memories. There is no Barak Obama
without Jesse Jackson. In fact, Barak Obama
is a Columbia University student who went
to see Jesse Jackson debate Mondale and the
rest in the campaign. And it's also about
Obama's uncanny ability to present himself
as a bridge between and among groups of peoples
in this patchwork quilt of a country in a
way that was absolutely unique. Barak Obama
did not become president because of his vast
legislative experience. Barak Obama did not
become president because of his uniqueness
ideologically. His politics with the exception
of a couple of issues particularly Iraq was
almost indistinguishable from his opponents
in the Democratic ledger particularly Hillary
Clinton. He did not become president of the
United States because he beat Hillary Clinton
in the debates. Arguably, Hillary Clinton
probably won as many as 17 out of 18 of those
debates depending on who's doing the watching.
He became President in some part because of
his ability to tell the story of his life
and his family's life and his view of the
world and make it emblematic of something
new. Emblematic of the urge for change that
people were feeling out of what a lot of people
saw as the wreckage of the Bush presidency.
So the book is very much a deeply reported
biography of Obama, which I'll talk about
in a second, but it's also the history of
the analysis of a storyteller. I don't mean
a bullshit artist. But someone who's able
to tell his story and make it larger. And
one of the ways that he was able to do this
before he ever entered big-time political
life was to write a memoir. And anybody here
read the memoir, "Dreams from My Father"?
I mean it certainly sold a lot of copies,
and if we don't by reading whole, then we
know it by the way was filtered down into
speeches, campaign interviews, rhetoric, and
all the rest. That "Dreams from My Father",
in a way, is the lodestar and the, the, the
raw materials of what we know is the Barak
Obama story. And it's told in a particular
way. He's a young man. Here's the background
of this book. It's very interesting.
Barak Obama is not a great high school student.
He's okay. He gets to Occidental, which is
a very good college. He does fine. He's a
"B" student. He transfers to Columbia he gets
more serious, a little bit more monastic about
his life. A lot of long runs, this kind of
lonely life. Or a more serious life, say.
He's not a, he's not a monk by any stretch
of the imagination, but he gets more serious.
But still, he is not summa cum laude, all
star student. He becomes a community organizer
and he learns a lot from it. He certainly
finds a home there. He finds a community.
He finds a greater sense of his depth as an
African-American, because in Hawaii you don't
get that because what few blacks live in Hawaii
live on military bases, right. So where he
really gets a sense of himself in terms of
ambition is at Harvard Law school. He becomes
the student of and the mentee of Laurence
Tribe, a great constitutional scholar, of
Martha Minot is the kind of democratic legal
scholar. He gets a lot more serious. It's
at that point in his life, and you've all
experienced it, where you find your, if you
are lucky, you find your groove intellectually.
And he finds it beyond measure. He becomes
a candidate for the Harvard Law Review presidency,
and because he's not only a liberal and attracts
liberal votes, but because he seems like the
kind of person who listens to people with
opposing views, he attracts conservative votes
and he wins. It's not a liberal versus conservative
election for the Harvard Law Review presidency.
It's one in which he faces another liberal
but the conservatives put him over the top.
So, if you ever wonder why he has that habit
of mind and that sense of himself, as somebody
who can do that, however impossible in the
United States Senate, that's partly where
it comes from. So he becomes the first African-American
president of the Harvard Law Review, and the
next morning there's a story in the New York
Times, there's a story in various other newspapers,
on the wire services, on television.
He becomes a little bit of a star and he gets
a phone call from "big bad New York" from
a literary agent. "Why don't you write a book?"
And some of the publishers are intrigued,
but they think, well, it must be the story
of somebody up from the ghetto, which Obama
had to laugh at, since he went to the fanciest
private school west of the Rocky Mountains
at Punahou School in Honolulu. I mean he himself
was not rich but he certainly went to an incredibly,
let's just say, well-equipped and pretty fancy
prep school in Hawaii. No, he decides to write
a memoir not about civil rights law or about
anything academic he decides to write a memoir
of himself. Remember this is the 90s when
in American writing, the memoir exploded.
There are all kinds of memoirs about being
one ethnic group or another. Memoirs about
addiction and recovery. Memoirs about all
kinds of experiences, and the memoir even
more than the novel dominated at least a novelty
aspect of American literature. And Obama joins
this stream. And he writes a young man's book
about becoming himself, about his absent father,
coming to terms with this father who is far
less of a wonderful personality than he ever
would have imagined. This book is the rough
materials of what becomes the political narrative
of Barak Obama. So that, at one point as I'm
telling the story of Obama's life and digging
more deeply into it in a reportorial way than
anybody writing a memoir could, I stopped
the narrative at that point and tried to analyze
what this book actually is. This book comes
out at the tradition of African-American memoir
writing that began in this country with 6000
slave narratives. You know, Frederick Douglas
and all the rest. It becomes in the tradition
of the autobiography of Malcolm X, which Obama
read very, very carefully as a teenager or
Richard Wright or James Baldwin or Maya Angelou
or all these books that we know a lot about.
Brent Staples for example. And the book is
a story about one's self. It's not fake but
it's crafted.
He tells you the conditions of his book. "I'm
going to make up some names here and there;
I'm going to fool around with the story to
give it some shape." And it's written in 3
parts, and each part ends with Barak Obama
in tears. It's not something we usually associate
with Barak Obama. He's not usually the most
emotive guy in the history of American politics.
He's known for his cool, more than he is for
his heat. But in this book, each part ends
with him in tears, whether it's because of
his coming to the church of Jeremiah Wright,
or because of his resolution about his feelings
about his father, or his wedding to Michelle
Obama on the south side of Chicago. It is
an emotional book far more than it is a political
book. It's a book about the, that very American
phenomenon of creating one's self, all right.
I wrote a book about Bob Dylan about 10 years
ago, 12 years ago called "King of the World".
Not Bob Dylan about Muhammad Ali, excuse me.
[Laughter]
The future is now. Although Bob Dylan is an
even better example of this, or just as good
of an example.
Muhammad Ali is a kid from segregated Louisville,
who's a good athlete. That's who he is. But
in order to create this thing called "Muhammad
Ali", he was Cassius Clay of course, he plucks
all sorts of things out of the cultural air,
and creates an identity for himself. He takes
the braggadocio of the professional wrestler
Gorgeous George, the speed and style of Sugar
Ray Robinson, and on and on and on. And he
creates the Malcom X and Elijah Muhammad,
and he creates the thing called "Muhammad
Ali". This happens in American popular culture
all the time.
Bob Dylan is a Jewish kid from the iron range
of Minnesota, named Robert Zimmerman. And
he takes what he's hearing on the radio Gene
Vincent, Hank Williams. I mean. Jewish kids
from Minnesota don't normally talk like this
[raspy voice.] They don't normally talk like
Muddy Waters crossed with Hank Williams. He
creates himself. He hitchhikes a ride to New
York City, and he enters the bloodstream of
Gerde's Folk City. That's the story you know
about him.
Barak Obama, in a very similar American sense,
does a bit of self-creating himself. Sometimes
when we hear him speaking, it sounds like
he's channeling the great black preachers
of mid-century. How did that happen via Honolulu
and Harvard Law school? He learned how to
do it. In other words, he is a shape shifter.
We all are in some ways, right. We talk a
certain way when we're with this group, and
a little bit different with this group. The
greatest orator in American history did it.
Martin Luther King Jr., easily the greatest
orator that we can certainly in memory, would
go into one kind of audience and make reference
to Paul Tillich and Karl Barth and all the
great tradition of European theologians, and
he'd go to a very different audience and it
was pretty down and dirty. Right? It was like
a small southern church, and he'd speak in
a different way but he was genuine. The reason
he was successful is that he was always himself.
Barak Obama had to learn how to do that. This
is not anything natural; anymore than it's
natural to become a great musician or great
athlete or great writer. Politics too has
its skill sets. And so Obama runs for State
Senate in 1996. That's the opening he finds,
and he's not very good at it. He's just okay.
But he's not running against anybody, and
he succeeds, and he gets into the State Senate.
And when he decides to run for Congress in
2000, he runs against a great active impiety.
He runs against Bobby Rush, former Black Panther
leader in the state of Illinois. Very popular,
not a great congressman, but very popular
and Barak Obama gets his butt kicked. He is
beaten by more than two to one. And his wife
and his friends, many of them say to him,
"You know, enough. You are a very talented
guy, you could do well and good," which means
you could make some dough, "please thank you
very much [laughter] and do good for the community".
He interviews to maybe lead one of the big
foundations in Chicago which had a salary
of $1 million in memberships and this, that,
and the other thing. It would have been a
pretty good life for Barak Obama, and he could
give away lots of money to kind of do good
organizations, the Woods Foundation. And he's
in the interview and his hands start to shake.
He comes out of the interview and the head
of the board says, "You know, of course you
can have this job but you don't want to do
this."
And he said, "Thank God." His hands were shaking,
not because he was worried "if" he would get
it; he was worried "that" he would get it,
and that he would quash his dreams forever
in politics.
So, he gets a kind of promissory note from
his wife. One more chance, you can run for
Senate in 2004, and here's where every big
life in American politics, or any other realm,
that skill is involved, intelligence is involved,
timing is involved, but sometimes luck is
really involved. And in the, try to look back
in this -- we look at this as if it were a
great political triumph that he wins the Senate
seat in 2004, but never forget the role of
good fortune, too. He runs in a crowded field
in the Democratic primary race. The leading
candidate, certainly the richest candidate,
is a guy who made a fortune in the financial
services initially on blackjack named Blair
Hull. Blair Hull is kind of an empty suit
in terms of politics. He doesn't have much
to say about the issues. He's got a lot of
dough, and he's spending it on buses and airplanes
and signs and commercials and he's in the
lead. I mean, who's Barak Obama? He's a state
senator; nobody knows who he is, and he lost
terribly in a congressional race. And it gets
down and dirty to the end. The Obama team
has not yet spent its money on media and what
happens? Blair Hull's divorce records are
open, and let's just say that they're filled
with things that you would not want to have
aired in public. Namely, that he had hit his
wife, and threatened her and all kinds of
things that are disqualifying in American
politics, if we're lucky. And he just goes
down in flames.
Obama wins the Democratic nomination. Now
he's going to a face a Republican that looks
very attractive. A kind of very good-looking
Kennedyesque, conservative named Jack Ryan,
who made a fortune at Goldman Sachs. And he
is married or had been married to an actress
named Jeri Ryan. Wait for it... who's on...
you all know what she's on, right. She's on
Star Trek, wearing a Lycra suit. She's a cyborg,
is she? I think it's something like that.
I knew you'd know. I knew you'd know. And
their divorce records get opened up, and that's
the end of Jack Ryan's campaign. Mention of
French sex clubs is not something that's going
to lead you to a great Republican Party career.
So, Obama is now two sex scandals ahead in
this Senate race, and he faces, who do the
Republicans come up with, does anybody remember
to face him? Alan Keyes, okay, who could not
beat a door if it were open. So by the time
that candidacy was over and -- oh, I forgot
the other stroke of good luck.
As he's campaigning, he gets a phone call
from Boston. "This is the John Kerry campaign.
Would you like to give the keynote address
at the Democratic Convention in Boston? We
hear you are very good speaker, and we're
looking out to give the speech to somebody
young and upcoming." "Sure I'd like to give
that speech," and he gives the speech of a
lifetime that you, my guess is, everybody
in this room first heard of Barak Obama, unless
you are from Illinois, that night as you were
watching the convention. And he gave the speech
that made his career; it certainly launched
his career. So, good luck is also part of
it.
And finally, I'll just say this. In trying
to write a biography about Barak Obama, one
has to be careful of mythologies. Mythologies.
And right now mythology is about who Obama
is, was, has been incredibly persists in American
life despite the best efforts of accurate
reporting. One of them I just got; I couldn't
believe it. I was speaking to another audience
and the first question from the crowd was,
"Was Barak Obama really born in Honolulu?"
So in modern politics, in modern campaigning,
and in the modern presidency there's no escaping
the persistence of rumor. There's no escaping
the persistence of scandalous insinuation,
especially when we live in an age of pervasive
media of the kind of media that we have, which
is all for the good, but it also has its flip
sides and when it comes to politics, this
is one of the symptoms of the flip side of
it.
So, I'll stop there. It gives you a very sketchy
view of what this book is which I hope is
a very deep biography that takes you from
birth in Honolulu, by the way, exactly as
advertised, to the door of the White House.
After talking to hundreds of people around
Obama, his friends, his enemies, his family
members, to Obama himself, and I hope you
get a chance to take a peek at it.
So if anybody has some questions or we can
have a conversation about him, I would be
thrilled to entertain it.
[Inaudible]
Sure, oh, that's right. There's a microphone
right there.
Female Audience Member: So I understand you
spoke to Obama as part of your research.
David: Mmm hmm.
Female Audience Member: What kinds of things
did you ask him about or look for clarity
about when you spoke to him?
David: Well, the final interview was in the
Oval Office. And as you can imagine, interviews
in the Oval Office are-they have a more formal
feel than an interview on the fly in a hallway
over cup of coffee on the road. You are in
the Oval Office, which is a striking feeling.
I'd never I'd never had... well I think maybe
I was on a tour once and saw it for 3 1/2
seconds, and it's like an Edgar Allan Poe
story. It's so quiet, you can hear the click-click-click
of a grandfather clock and you've got a limited
time. And we talked in particular about the
role of race in the campaign, which is a very
complicated subject. And all this is in the
epilogue of the book. And we also talked about
some of what I was getting at the very end
here -- the persistence of ugliness of things
on the fringes. And Obama is, you know, he,
he, both good, bad, and indifferent; he's
a very cool customer. He said, 'Look, I am
perfectly aware,' and I'm paraphrasing here,
'that the combination of economic insecurity
for a lot of people, unemployment, all the
rest, coupled with the advent of a historical
presidency -- the first African-American in
the presidency -- is going to create a lot
of anxiety and some other combustible especially
at its fringes. And this is the way he is
with everything. There's a certain kind of
almost preternatural unflappability, which
he can, seems to confront everything at least
that's his public face. That's what it felt
like to me. I don't think, in other words,
if I were interviewing Bill Clinton in the
Oval Office, I would not have heard the grandfather
clock.
[Quiet laughter]
Female Audience Member #2: I was wondering
how one launches oneself out into this sort
of project. That is, I mean, your name is
already well known. So that would give you
some entrée with this project that might
not have been the case in your early projects,
but there are already a lot of... there's
books that Obama has written and there's all
this stuff on him. How did it come to be that
you put this…
David: You know what, it's a great question,
and I needed to prove that for myself. I was
not actually, weirdly, I was not given pause
by the autobiography, because I know – Look,
there is an autobiography of Benjamin Franklin
and then there is Walter Isaacson's Benjamin
Franklin. They're entirely two different animals.
Autobiography is the story that you tell about
yourself and it's quite limited and his book
stops at politics. And after all why are we
interested in him? In large measure because
of politics. There's no political races – there's
no anything like that. It stops at him getting
married. Although we learn something about
his political instincts when he discusses
his career as a community organizer for example.
But I had written a long piece for the New
Yorker that came out just after the election,
called "The Joshua Generation" that hit some
of the themes that I began with today. It
was very particularly about race in the election.
Not long after, John Updike died, an important
writer not only in America but for our magazine,
and somebody I felt close to, and I felt enormous
gratitude toward, and there was no way I wasn't
going to go to this funeral which was in a
small town north of Boston. I went to the
funeral, and afterwards stayed in Cambridge
for a few days and talked with some of the
professors and colleagues that Obama had had
at Harvard University just to see what some
intensive interviewing and talking and feeling
around would yield. And if I felt that well
in fact, I already know this stuff, this sounds
very familiar, I'm not interested in pursuing
it, because a book is an investment of time,
energy, and all the rest. And I've got a day
job. I'm editing a magazine. And I need to
keep my eyes on that. So if I'm going to do
this, and I'm going to do very late nights
and very very early mornings and all the weekends
imaginable, I gotta want to do it. Books that
don't really want being done inevitably are
terrible books. They're dull books. They're
listless books. They reflect the disinterest
of the author. And I wouldn't put myself in
that position, and ultimately I don't want
to put the reader in that position. And those
few days, followed up by some more interviewing,
and the experiment of writing the chapter
or the early draft on the Harvard Law School
business gave me the idea that, you know what,
I think I'm going to do this.
Male Audience Member: So Obama was raised
by a white mother and white grandparents and
in generally very white areas in white schools.
And somewhere down the line became very involved
in black civil rights kinds of movements.
What do you think triggered that? From college
or was it political expediency?
David: I don't think it was political expediency.
I think it's partly looking in the mirror;
it's partly a search for who you are, and
this is why the father is such a haunting
figure to him, because he provides part of
his genetics. And whether he liked it or not,
part of the legacy that he had to struggle
to understand. And you know identity is a
funny thing. Identity is partly given to you
by birth, by chromosomes. It's also something
that you have a say in, right? Your parents
can be Orthodox Jews -- you can choose to
not be that. You can't choose to be other
things, necessarily, very easily. You can't
choose to be Japanese if you're an Orthodox
European Jew. But there's a range in which
you do have -- an identity, at least in part,
is something that you have a say in. And in
so far that he had a say in it, he pursued
an identity as an African-American. Now, a
lot of a -- most African-Americans don't have
to pursue anything. It's right there at the
kitchen table as well as right there genetically.
It's right there in the neighborhood. It's
right there in school. And so on. With Obama,
he had to go out and pursue it, and so he
did.
Male Audience Member #2: You mentioned, rightly
so, that Obama was largely elected not on
a legislative background or at least a long
legislative background
David: Not very much.
Male Audience Member #2: But, so he was largely
elected then on his personal qualities and
visibility to shape the story as you put it.
David: And many other things. And certain
other talents, look he's not without, he was
in the U.S. Senate. He was a state senator.
There have been other presidents, previously,
that did not exactly have unbelievably long
careers. John Kennedy's one.
Male Audience Member #2: I was just wondering
in your kind of...
David: I will say that I did reject, even
though I voted for him, and the magazine endorsed
him. I thought it was unfair for people to
dismiss the experience question as not on.
I think it was very much on.
Male Audience Member #2: That wasn't what
I was trying to get at.
David: Yeah.
Male Audience Member #2: What are the qualities
that served him so well in the campaign? His
ability to tell his story? And exhibit, uh,
David: I think also campaigning discipline.
Male Audience Member #2: Male#2: But let what
were those qualities that maybe have not served
him so well as president?
David: Well, I think that he has to his chagrin
discovered that this habit of mind and emotions
and his belief in his capacity to reconcile
and square the circle all the time, comes
up against the hard reality of the nature
of the Senate and the Congress, the nature
foreign leaders who are not to be reconciled,
necessarily. I don't think he is naïve about
this. I just think it's very different from
running a Harvard Law Review presidency than
it is to deal with Mahmoud Ahmadinejad. But
I'm not suggesting that I knew it and he didn't.
I'm just suggesting that it's, you know, and
also the old saying about politics is you
run in poetry and you govern in prose. And
this disappoints a lot of people, especially
a lot of young people whose first political
investment in their lives was an enthusiasm
for Obama and now they're sometimes disappointed
in this issue or that or one that compromise
or the other. Yes. We should take these two
and maybe wrap it up. Yeah.
Male Audience Member #3: I want to first thank
you for coming,
David: My pleasure
Male Audience Member #3: and for writing this
book. And I wanted to ask you if your perception
of the Republican Party's reaction to Obama
and their obstructionism is in some way related
to his ability to bridge gaps and to bridge
different groups together? And if it is something
that they really can't find a good way in
ideologically so they're finding different,
a more...
David: I think it's a variety. I think you
shouldn't make a cartoon of Republicans anymore
and then we make a cartoon of people maybe
you feel closer to politically. I think there's
sincere, earnest avenues of disagreement with
Obama on any number, all issues. I mean that's,
that's good, however you may disagree with
it. For example, on health care it is completely
legitimate to raise the issue of cost; it
is not legitimate to raise the issue of death
panels. So one thing does not always equal
the other. Okay?
Male Audience Member #3: Yes.
David: Alright. Listen, thank you for having
me. This was a great pleasure.
[Applause]